from a must to no longer mandatory the
decision to wear a mask is becoming a
personal choice i really hope that
everyone who comes in the store respects
our feelings on the matter experts say
it's understandable why the latest
lifting of long-standing public health
measures has some feeling hesitant
really hoping we're coming out finally
and in an exhausted state as we do while
at the same time half expecting that
we're going to get pushed right back
into it again a possibility that's left
many stressed anxious and even depressed
social psychologist amy cuddy calls this
pandemic flux syndrome
we're in a prolonged liminal state and a
liminal state is where we sort of have
one foot on the safe side and one foot
on the threatened side and we're really
not sure
where to place our weight our surge
capacity a collection of adaptive
systems that we use for survival in very
stressful situations is shot we've been
warned that restrictions could come back
at any time covid hasn't disappeared and
in fact we're seeing a spike in omicron
cases globally we're even seeing that
here in canada in wastewater in alberta
and saskatchewan we almost expect these
numbers to increase a little because of
the release or you know relief from some
of the precautions despite this there
are calls to see the federal government
lift all remaining mandates and in the
u.s the white house is being lobbied to
remove one of its last
masks on planes i don't like the covid
it's dangerous but i'm tired of the mess
for many it will take more than removing
a mask to move on
for a fresh start cuddy says it may come
down to a conscious choice
we are very
psychologically resilient our
psychological immune systems are strong
and most of us will get through this and
return to our baseline level
taking the time we need to recalibrate
and adjust to our new normal jamie
morocco global news toronto